d'accord maintenant arrêter réglisse à
toi
[Musique]
faut que je dise un truc bon vieux t'as
rien perdu tu as tous les mouvements
je te croyais mort et enterré bah moi
aussi frenchy crois moi mais je te
raconterai plus tard deux jours trois
clients ni vu du connecter ce tandis que
les séries ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est
quoi ça c'est propre c'est silencieux et
façon pas le fauve à l'intérieur
d'accord suivez-moi ce représentant de
chaussures anglaises est au courant de
qui je suis si le fric est prêt et toi
tu nous le donne
c'est quoi ton problème elle nous a filé
fric trop facilement à mon goût
[Musique]
j'en ai plus que marre d'être violent
c'est terminé allez vas-y ma puce
ap ap le bon temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]